i love this television show yeah
my wife
susie loves his television when susie
and i watch ted lasso and the credits
roll
we are invariably looking at each other
doing two things one
saying when is the next one
when can we see the next one please tell
me there are more of them
and the other thing is we are we're like
drying our eyes it is a beautiful
television show
it is funny
it is beautiful
it is inspiring
it is moving
it is
all that plus the biscuit and part of
the reason why is not just the writing
but it is the acting
in it as well and thrilled to have here
on the rich eisen show
on the mercedes-benz vans phone line is
a man who plays nate nate the great who
has gone from team i guess assistant and
trainer or what have you uh all the way
up to coaching and now uh even uh
rival my gosh the actor nick muhammad
here on the rich eisen show how you
doing nick
hey rich i'm really good thanks so much
for having me a pleasure just a pleasure
you are awesome in your job you are
awesome at what you do and this show is
incredible i'm i'm sure you hear that a
lot so let me just add very very kind of
you thank you thank you so um when you
first took this job
was was your character's storyline arc
mapped out for you at the time nick i
believe i believe it was yeah um i i
quite distinctly remember we were
filming i think the gala episode in
season one which is around about episode
three or four and it was it was before
seasons two and three had been
commissioned but i remember jason sort
of sitting me down and just sort of
explaining to me the broad kind of
arc for nate if this was to kind of go
from season to season so so yeah i mean
you know it just goes to show how smart
that
kind of those writers and creators are
in the writers room just you know they
had it all mapped out and not you know
not just the nate they've got everyone's
character arcs kind of mapped out and um
yeah and when he obviously told me i was
i was kind of both thrilled and
terrified because i kind of knew it was
going to take such a heel turn in um in
season two i mean my gosh nate i got to
be honest with you i was disappointed
i'm disappointed in you
i'm disappointed in you you're not the
person to say i mean a lot of people a
lot of people have
quite rightly as well been sort of
disappointed by
nate's actions and his behavior you know
whether it's part of a redemption arc i
i genuinely don't know i mean we
literally start filming you know next
week oh you do i i i yeah we do and i've
i've i'm yet to see the script here i
kind of don't i don't have all the
details to have fabulous
so um you get handed them and i imagine
you pour over them just like any other
fan would like i would that's for darn
sure right
i mean i think i think people forget
particularly
fans of the show like as a cast we're
all you know some of the biggest fans of
the show as well so when yeah when we
get sent these scripts we're you know
desperate to know not just obviously
what's happening to the characters that
we play but you know i want to know
about roy and keaney and they want to
know more about ted and you know what's
going to happen with rebecca you know
there's so many you know
storylines that i'm kind of equally
excited by and uh yeah so we pour over
those scripts as soon as we get them
actor nick mohamed who plays nate nate
the great here
from ted lasso on the rich eisen show um
and i would imagine uh so do you have a
real life side team that you root for in
any way shape or form
you know what i don't sadly i i kind of
am not a huge football fan which is uh
you know my dad is uh and uh
and he's delighted that i'm finally sort
of you know in a show about football but
i you know i never really played it as a
kid and i think he probably wanted me to
yeah so i i don't really have a team at
all though but you know the scenario in
in in the premier league where somebody
like ted lasso comes in and takes over a
club what the reaction would be i mean
this is oh yeah yeah so i i kind of knew
enough to sort of uh you know kind of
get through and you know i guess i mean
weirdly ted after sort of taught a lot
more about football than i previously
knew so
yeah and and you know the character roy
kent is spot on right played by brett
goldstein like that that is exactly
who somebody who uh would
would be like and i i i you know the
football player here in america aaron
rodgers came on our show a few months
ago and he said he would love to be the
roy kent of the nfl whenever he retires
just go on tv and just lay waste to
everybody you know like that yeah i i
love that character it's such a sort of
a almost like elder statesman kind of
quality to it that you know now he's
matured and i guess retired from the
sport that he can now he can really sort
of say how it is and uh it doesn't
certainly doesn't hold back nick
mohammed here on the rich eisen show
again he plays uh nate the great here on
on the program um so which is your
favorite moment for your character in
the first two seasons where oh goodness
you know what this is a a great scenery
it could be a good line good funny line
it could be a laugh line it could be a
line that uh that is the exact opposite
or scene or what have you which one is
that for you
in season one i you know i really liked
the the roast where he i think i think
his episode seven where he roasts the
players he he thinks that you know he's
written down all this stuff about the
players
and and he gives it to ted thinking
ted's gonna do it and then ted sort of
throws it back in and says no you're
gonna do it and he so he approached it
really nervously but then
you know manages to kind of get into his
stride and that that was just a fun
scene to do because i think it marks a
kind of good turning point in terms of
the characters
trajectory in season one in particular
in terms of building confidence and it
was just a fun thing to do with all
those you know the guys who play the
footballers it was just fun sort of
pretending to lay into them and uh that
was that was a fun one and then i guess
even though it wasn't particularly nice
to
perform you know the the
the
the final scene between ted and nate in
fact the only scene purely between ted
and nate and season two is where he
massively lays into him in episode 12 in
the season finale and uh
he you know he just tells him that he
feels abandoned and that he's you know
that ted's let him down he really laid
into him and it was yeah it's just you
know it was it's quite quite painful to
do and you know
jason is so brilliant and and you know
it felt very real as well it felt kind
of quite raw we talked about it for a
long long time and you know i knew that
it was kind of coming for a long a long
time while we were filming season two
that it was all going to be kind of
building towards this point so once we
filmed it it was kind of a bit of a sort
of release of pressure but
it was a difficult one to do but but i
think a fulfilling one to do ultimately
as well what do you mean talk about it
for a long time what do you mean by that
well we've
i guess i guess we had
you know
we
i knew that that scene that that there
was going to be this outburst between
nate and ted at some point but i knew
that it didn't come till season 12. so a
lot
of often there were so many kind of
moments in season two where nate would
give ted a look or there'd be something
unspoken between them and jason and you
know the other writing creators on that
show would always say you just gotta
kind of
save this feeling because it's not gonna
you know you're not gonna get to
explicitly say what you want to say as
nate until
the very end of the season
but you kind of we have to sort of show
this mounting pressure so we sort of we
just sort of spoke about the kind of
that that
and that sort of growing unease inside
of nate and and him just
you know
getting sort of so tense between him and
the other players and his attitude
towards ted until finally in episode 12
he kind of erupts and you know
the damn breaks and he just says
everything that he probably shouldn't
have said but but kind of have to at
this point in terms of dams breaking
who's the easiest to crack up on this on
on the show
hannah hannah's quite hannah's quite
easy to break she is
yeah
yeah hannah
hannah and i sort of
sort of share a kind of knowing glance
that sets us off
jeremy who plays higgins really
knows how to kind of crack me up i think
just with a little sound or a little
sideways look that that cracks but all
of us i mean
you know brett as well laughs a lot phil
laughs a lot um you know we're we're so
lucky to be a part of the show because
we get to kind of go to work and have a
have a good old gig
it's a joy it's certainly it certainly
is from from my point of view just
sitting there and again
uh my wife and i watch it i do believe
you're going to speak to her as soon as
you hang up from me uh for her podcast
yes nick and i appreciate that so yeah
you're you're going to you're you're
it's a family affair for you this
morning um but you know it's just so
moving for us and it's so beautiful for
us and and
we're like lamenting every single time
an episode ends and then the long wait
so
is this really the last season the one
that you're shooting or is there i
genuinely don't know i mean i
i think that
from a from a story point of view i know
that jason has said and brendan have
said quite openly that they had three
seasons in mind for the story that they
wanted to tell
who knows what might happen after then
but i genuinely don't know i'm not i'm
not being deliberately evasive or
anything okay i just um i'm yeah i kind
of
i both hope it's not because it's been
such a joy and it's so great getting to
act with
those people uh you know we're together
sort of the six months of the year
but then equally if if they feel that
the story is sold after three seasons
then i really respect that as you know
as writers i think that's a smart thing
to do rather than fizzle out but you
know who knows who knows let's see and
then obviously you know there's there's
uh other projects for you to do in your
career and intelligence is seen right
here on peacock we're on peacock right
now um you know with you and david
schwimmer and and
you know and my wife and i were also um
huge fans of game of thrones and did did
did you know right away that hannah
waddingham was was the shame uh none i
did you did know that
it took me a long time to realize that
that was a huge epiphany for my wife and
i
that must have been huge yeah because
it's a yeah it's a great that's such a
great iconic kind of moment in game of
thrones as well so i uh yeah having that
moment must have been fun for you on
your way because it's a big one we're
like oh my god how can that be the same
um person an actress and then she sings
and then she sings in the karaoke
episode and it's incredible she's
remarkable you know she's phenomenal
well that yeah i mean hannah you know
hannah was brought up you know that's
her bread and butter you know for years
and years being
you know incredible musical theater and
she has i mean she's just got the most
phenomenal voice it's so great that you
know we get to kind of
see that not not just at that in the
karaoke scene but in the funeral scene
that's
she rick rolled everybody she rick
rolled the whole she rick athlete
everybody so uh that was incredible
incredible the show is great you're
great nick thanks for the time really
appreciate it man thank you for the call
so much thank you
right back at you at nick muhammad on
twitter uh everyone can watch the first
two episodes of ted lasso first two
seasons of ted lasso on apple tv and if
you haven't done it yet i'm jealous
that you are new to it hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here